I see these people that go crazy album
goes number one but then they can't fill
up a show right so the math is not math
right it's one of those things that like
everyone in the industry knows is going
on which is faking streams a real thing
streaming Farms or we're delving out
computers in third world
countries and hacking the back end to
make it look like it's an IP from the US
whatever like all this nutty but
they're not doing it with like up and
cominging artists who like you wouldn't
believe it let's say your song has 500
million streams right organically but
let's say with fake streams now you're
at 900 million no one's going to sit
there and be like this is more like a
500 million stream song they're just
going to be like this is a big song
makes sense it has 900 million the
streams might be fake but me being
perceived as a massive artist make Mone
you can mze so now it's all just a
finesse and it's all a SC